hoch im norden von niedersachsen in
wingst gibt es jede menge ärger saftiges
grün und mittendrin diesen nagelneuen
bahnübergang großflächig asphaltiert mit
sage und schreibe sieben ampeln und fünf
andreaskreuzen aber das prachtstück
verbindet nicht etwa zwei viel befahrene
bundesstraßen sondern diesen schotterweg
mit diesem schotterweg es ist unsinnig
weil hier feldwege sind es ist unsinnig
absoluter schwachsinn absoluter
schwachsinn das ist rausgeschmissenes
geld wir nutzen den bahnübergang mit
einer handvoll landwirte wir kamen mit
dem alten bahnübergang der in den 60er
jahren glaube ich gebaut wurde
genau so zurecht wie wie immer also
dieser ist völlig überdimensioniert
am bahnübergang in wingst war noch nie
viel los ab und zu fährt man ein trecker
auf dem weg vom bahnhof zum feld über
die schienen mehr als eine handvoll
fahrzeuge pro tag ist hier nicht
unterwegs weil es am bahnübergang immer
wieder probleme mit der veralteten
technik gab musste er erneuert werden
nach jahrelanger planung wird dann in
großem stil gebaut
das ergebnis ein völlig
überdimensionierte bahnübergang mitten
im nirwana kosten rund 900.000 euro die
gemeinde wingst musste sich an den
kosten beteiligen bürgermeister patrick
pawlowski fällt aus allen wolken als er
den fertigen übergang sieht ein
einspurigen feldweg der dann mündet in
einen stehtisch anmutenden bahnübergang
und dann wieder in einen feldweg mündet
da hätte ich mir schon gewünscht dass
man eine vernünftige planung vorne
laut deutscher bahn musste der übergang
aus sicherheitsgründen so groß gebaut
werden schriftlich heißt es ein
begegnungsverkehr im bereich des
bahnübergangs kann nicht ausgeschlossen
werden daher musste im rahmen der
planung sichergestellt werden dass kein
fahrzeug auf dem bahnübergang zum stehen
kommt diese begründung können die
landwirte in wingst überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen
man kann von allen drei straßen
richtungen sehen kommt er was muss ich
moment warten oder kann nicht
durchfahren also man sieht der bahn über
schön über
in der der breite ist einfach nicht
nötig wo sind wir hier mitten in der
stadt
dass er so ein pompöses stück gebaut
wird ein teurer hightech bahnübergang
für begegnungsverkehr
obwohl sich niemand begegnet denn
vielmehr wird hier auch in den nächsten
jahren nicht los sein